in lesson three there's
three concepts that i would like to
talk about one is you get to see
some different forms of the pronoun i
as in ger and then we have mua which is
me uh you'll see more and more examples
of the
ways in which the pronouns i
you he it changed
in french so you get your first look at
it here we also
have another look at the verb etta to be
in some different forms you should
become familiar with that and you will
gradually
not to worry and we see the
french double barrelled negative
so the lesson begins with this excuse
moi which is very similar to english
excuse me so the excuse here is an order
excuse me now normally we would add
silver play please please excuse me but
this is a way of saying about your
pardon excuse me
excuse him what and we notice that the
muah here
is me and we see the atvu
ru so we have et vu is the question
are you and joshui so sui
is just a form of the verb so is
it at we've seen that before and we will
see it very often
and you'll gradually get used to the
different forms
of this verb and of course
we're introduced to the idea that if you
are not je
they sort of sandwich the verb and
you'll see
many examples of the french negative
sandwich at any rate just listen to the
lesson
read it save your words and phrases and
gradually
things will become clearer